After delivering a stunning finale to
Marvel's "Guardians of the Galaxy" trilogy,
James Gunn has proven that he knows how to handle
cosmic heroes with complex emotions. And that’s
exactly what Superman needs right now.
Some spoilers for Guardians
of the Galaxy Vol. 3 ahead.
Is Gunn really right for Superman?
James Gunn’s appointment as the head of
DC’s cinematic universe seemed logical.
The director had made some of Marvel’s best
films with the “Guardians of the Galaxy” series,
and he delivered the most acclaimed DC movie
in years, “The Suicide Squad,” in 2021.
But you might wonder why Gunn would choose to
write and direct a new Superman movie himself.
The character has been hard to adapt for the
big screen in the modern era, and Henry Cavill’s
version, though popular with some fans, didn’t
last. Gunn also has a knack for witty sarcasm that
suits “Guardians of the Galaxy,” but might clash
with the Man of Steel. So the question remains: Is
Gunn the right choice to direct a Superman movie?
"That's a good question."
After watching “Guardians of the Galaxy Vol.
3,” the answer is a clear yes. Though the two
franchises differ in style and tone, “Vol. 3”
shows how good Gunn is at the things that count:
character development, emotional resonance,
and heart. Amidst all the humor and colorful
alien settings, the movie returns to what
made the MCU great, honoring both its
heroes and the time fans have spent with them.
In short, “Guardians of the Galaxy Vol. 3” has
sold us on James Gunn’s “Superman: Legacy” movie.
What Superman is all about
Superman’s bright outfit, catchy name, and
dedication to helping those in need set the
standard for everything that followed, including
the modern comic book blockbuster industry.
But the world of caped comic characters has
changed a lot since then. It’s not enough to
just save people anymore – you need over-the-top
enemies, a multiverse, and countless crossovers.
Maybe it’s the simplicity of his
costume or his Swiss army knife powers,
but Superman has managed to stay above the noise,
and still represents the spirit of those golden
days. Clark Kent is known for being good, and
kind, and brave, and true, even in the darkest
of times. He does the right thing, which is
why we love superheroes in the first place.
"Guardians of the Galaxy Vol. 3" understands
that message. It’s accurate in its portrayal
of what makes its heroes heroic. In the
film’s final act, the team fights through
a whole ship of bad guys; not to kill the
main villain or find the last Infinity Stone,
but to save the many innocents trapped there.
Kids, aliens, baby animals – every single life
matters, and they all get out alive. After nearly
a decade of action-packed climaxes and battles
against Thanos and his ilk, the Guardians end
their trilogy by saving lives, not doing stunts.
And that’s what Superman is all about.
Characters, not cameos
Marvel Studios has had plenty of hits since the
Infinity Saga ended, including "Loki", "Black
Panther: Wakanda Forever," and "WandaVision."
"What is grief, if not love persevering?"
But there have also been more
than a few duds. At its worst,
the franchise has become a focus-tested
mishmash of setups, Easter eggs,
and "spot the cameo" moments. Fortunately,
"Guardians of the Galaxy Vol. 3" is the good
kind of Marvel movie -- one that focuses on real
character development instead of cheap callbacks.
"Vol. 3" cashes in on nine years of buildup.
We get to see Nebula become an inspiring
leader after a tragic, rage-filled life. Rocket
overcomes his immense trauma and finally accepts
himself as he is. These arcs work because of how
much time we've all spent with the characters.
Though he's a larger-than-life figure, Superman
needs that same kind of attention. The character
fails when he's treated as less than a person and
more than a god -- a titanic emblem of goodness
with no actual arc to speak of. The appeal
of Kal-El is that he chooses to be Superman,
time after time, even though he could just
as easily conquer all of Earth in an instant.
Additionally, Superman needs to stand on his
own, apart from any other sub-series or Justice
League teammates. If he is to be the heart of
Gunn's new DCU, it needs to be a heart that
beats and bleeds, and not just a logo.
The emotional core of "Guardians"
Though they're still silly more often than they're
not, the "Guardians of the Galaxy" films may also
be the most emotionally complex in all of the
MCU. Each one of the main characters is deeply
flawed and haunted by the ghosts of their pasts.
Over the course of the story, they're all forced
to confront their traumas, ultimately finding
new things to fight for and ways to improve
themselves. "Guardians of the Galaxy Vol. 3"
continues with that trend, giving the team an
emotionally resonant sendoff.
"That is the gist of it."
Gunn's ability to handle messy characters and
emotionally muddled storylines makes him a
great choice for the DCU, and for Superman
in particular. Clark Kent might seem like
a much more sunshine-and-rainbows character than
other DC heroes like Batman or John Constantine,
but telling his story the right way requires an
understanding of the complicated world around him.
He too is a man born of tragedy, shipped away
from his family and his entire home planet while
just a baby. Out of that tragedy, and with the
guidance of some compassionate adoptive parents,
he discovers the drive to help the
helpless wherever they might be.
Superman's strength is born of grief, just
like the Guardians of the Galaxy. Hopefully,
Gunn's strong track record of writing
nuanced comic book character arcs will
parlay into a fantastic Man of Steel film.
What "Superman: Legacy" could look like
Few details have been revealed about James
Gunn's Superman movie, which is set to be
released in 2025. However, the writer-director
has dropped a couple of clues. Speaking about
the script on Twitter in March of 2023, Gunn
said that the story will largely focus on,
"Superman's heritage - how both his aristocratic
Kryptonian parents and his Kansas farmer parents
inform who he is and the choices he makes."
What exactly does that have to do with
"Guardians of the Galaxy Vol. 3?" Well, a lot,
actually. Consider Rocket's arc in the third
"Guardians" film. He has to deal with a violent
and complicated history in order to become the
hero he knows he can be. Sound familiar?
How about Nebula and Gamora, who both have
to grapple with their dark upbringing by Thanos
in order to take ownership of their lives? For
his entire comic book movie career, Gunn has been
telling stories about how our history shapes us;
about how it determines our paths, and
the ways we can break away from it.
From the sound of it, Gunn's "Superman:
Legacy" will be as much about Krypton
as Earth. For a director who's built
his reputation on the backs of sci-fi
superhero movies, that makes a lot of sense.
Of course, the two will still be quite different,
with Gunn telling Rolling Stone in April 2023,
"It's not like Superman is going to have
exactly the same vibe as a Guardians
movie. It's actually quite different."
We still have a while to wait before Gunn's
Superman vision becomes clear, but "Guardians
of the Galaxy Vol. 3" is a strong endorsement
of what the director could be cooking up.